[Music]
welcome to Tucker Carlson tonight
February 13th was a relatively quiet day
on Wall Street it's not going to be
noted in any economics textbooks 200
years from now the Dow dropped about a
hundred points but just the day before
the dad reached an all-time high so the
loss didn't seem like a big deal overall
it was a calm steady week in the markets
but for one investor in Washington
February 13th was packed with drama
Richard burr is a Republican senator
from North Carolina burr has no
background in finance or investing in
fact before being elected to Congress in
1994 burr spent 17 years selling
lawnmowers for a dealer in winston-salem
but on February 13th of this year bursts
seem to develop very strong feelings
about the future of emeriti American
equity markets that day he dumped up to
1.7 million dollars in stocks and 33
separate transactions burr bought
nothing that day was a flurry of selling
sell sell sell essentially was a cash
out in fact it was two years ago roll
call estimated that burr had a total net
worth of about 1.7 million dollars in
other words that day in February Richard
burr suddenly decided to sell virtually
everything he owned many people on Wall
Street probably envied him now pretty
savvy move so what did Richard Byrd the
former lawnmower salesman know that the
financial experts did not know well a
lot it turns out Richard burr is the
chairman of the Senate Intelligence
Committee January 24th he attended a
closed-door briefing on the Chinese
coronavirus he was delivered by dr.
Anthony foul he and the head of the CDC
apparently what Burr heard there spooked
him within a short time he acted
decisively to save his family from
financial harm unfortunately he didn't
tell the rest of us about it in fact he
did just the opposite
burr hid what he knew about the
coronavirus threat and then lied about
it at length to the nation in a February
7th op-ed published on our website here
at Fox burr wrote this quote the United
States is better prepared than ever
before to face emerging public health
threats like the corona virus better
prepared than ever
Byrne knew that was a lie when he wrote
it six days later he dumped his entire
portfolio by March 5th a month later
no virus had become a full-blown crisis
in Italy yet Richard Burr was still
falsely insisting that everything was
fine he issued a statement assuring
America that quote we have a framework
in place that has put us in a better
position than any other country to
respond to a public health threat like
the corona virus that was burrs line in
public in private he was panicked on
February 27th before an audience at a
closed speech in Washington Burk
compared coronavirus to the Spanish flu
a pandemic that killed close to a
hundred million people there's one thing
I can tell you about this it is much
more aggressive in his transition than
anything that we have seen in recent
history it's probably more kin to for a
public servant it's pretty hard to
imagine many things more immoral than
doing this Richard burr had critical
information that might have helped the
people he is sworn to protect but he hid
that information and helped only himself
instead of sounding the alarm alerting
the country goading the government into
action as an ethical person would have
done burr told the easy lies that in the
end may have killed people and he wasn't
alone in doing that Dianne Feinstein is
a Democrat from California she also sits
on the Senate Intelligence Committee in
late January and early February of this
year Feinstein dumped up to six million
dollars worth of stock when confronted
with this fact today Feinstein dodged
she took the strikingly unfeminist
position that selling the stock was her
husband's decision to make and somehow
she was not allowed to ask about it all
those confusing numbers it's too much
for a girl please at times this winner
Feinstein to her credit did issue press
releases calling attention to the
seriousness of coronavirus and getting
good for her but all of her major public
statements were political on February
4th when every informed person in the US
government understood that the krona
virus was a very serious threat to the
world
Feinstein spent her time giving a long
speech on the Senate floor calling for
Donald Trump's conviction in the
impeachment trial and then there's Kelly
waffler a new Republican senator from
Georgia financial disclosure forms show
that Loffler sold up to 3.1 million
dollars in stock over three weeks after
being privately briefed in the Senate on
coronavirus la fleurs disclosure shows a
total of 29
equities transactions 27 of them were
sales some of the holdings she shed were
an energy automotive retail and Airlines
one of her two purchases was a company
called Citrix which makes teleworking
software that's a product suddenly in
high demand so that story broke last
night all these did unlike Richard Burr
senator la fleurs responded very
aggressively and quickly and in some
detail she said that her holdings are
managed by outside advisers she has
nothing directly to do with it and point
it to a financial disclosure that she
says she received days after the
transactions were made showing that
they've gone through it got to her on
February 16th we're happy to have
senator Lafleur join us tonight for more
on the story Welcome Center loftware we
appreciate them coming on thank you
thank you it's so you've been very clear
unlike senator burr as I said who hasn't
really explained how this happened
though I think it's pretty evident you
said right away I didn't know this
happened
I'd nothing to do with it I learned on
February 16th so can you tell us tonight
who made who specifically made this
decision to sell these equities and why
do you think they made that decision
well Tucker let me start at the
beginning when I was appointed to the
Senate what I did is I spent time with
lawyers making sure I understood not
only SEC requirements around being in
the Senate because I come from the
private sector I have 20 years of
experience in financial services right
but I also spent time making sure I
understood the stock act and the rules
under the Senate ethic committee for how
we perform our financial transactions I
decided that I was going to maintain the
same posture that I had in the financial
services industry which was to have a
third party person that was a set of
advisers that were fully charged and
able to make these transactions on my
own so that I did not have to be
involved in any of the decision-making
around these financial transactions and
that worked very well in the private
sector it kept us from having to have
concerns around insider trading and
that's what I maintained in the Senate
and that has allowed me to be able to
work hard for the American people and
focus on the things that I write in here
to Washington to do oh okay I understand
that let me just back up though and ask
you so they're in the set of
transactions that have been publicly
available there
29 27 of them as we noted were sell too
or buy it was a pretty strong market at
the time a lot of people weren't doing
what you did and the stocks that were
shed some of them not all I mean this
mixed bag to some extent but some of
them were stocks that really got
hammered so I'm just wondering I'm not
accusing you of anything but I'm
wondering again who made that who
specifically made that decision for you
and on what basis do you think so Tucker
that would be the financial advisors
that are charged with conducting trades
in our portfolios which we don't have a
say over and you know I think the most
important thing is that I am informed
only after those trades are made I have
nothing
you know in terms of a say and what buys
and sells are executed what that timing
is and I'm only advised after it happens
almost concurrent with the public
reporting that we do here okay well that
makes it so you you said you received
notice of this you've got the list of
the stocks that when sold and the two
that were purchased on February 16th so
not that long after that so you knew I
mean wow they're selling oh they're
selling a lot of lot of equities here I
want to put on on our screen for our
viewers a video that you released after
you learned this and here it is the good
news is the consumer is strong the
economy is strong jobs are growing our
president has done a fantastic job
making sure that we're in the best
position to manage through this
situation so I wonder I mean you you
said you looked at this in the you spent
all those years in business and you
notice that they're dumping retail for
example what people weren't doing that I
mean somewhere but most weren't and then
you shoot a video saying that the
economy is totally fine do you in
retrospect think maybe you should have
hinted that maybe it's not fine
obviously I mean just by your your
portfolio sheet you know that right well
look Tucker this situation has
dramatically changed in the space of
three months I think none of us could
have predicted where we would be today
and I think that's why it's important
that I'm not involved in stock
transactions I don't want to have to
explain my actions three months ago that
I don't need to take if I can no no no
this wasn't hold on I'm sure with with
respect this wasn't three months ago
this was a month ago in February 16th or
17th when you
receive this she did it trip any bells
for you I mean you can read a balance
sheet obviously it's what you did all of
your life until recently did you think
maybe this pretends something ominous
for the economy did that thought cross
your mind
Tucker this is a kind of normal course
for managing portfolios some some months
you have buys and sells some months you
have by some once you have sells
I trust the professionals that manage
our portfolio I don't get involved there
I don't have to say I don't want to have
a say I want to focus on my work for
Georgians we will be talking about cars
right now I get it I get it well then
and I'm not again I'm not accusing you
of executing the trades yourself it
sounds like you didn't and I don't you
know I'm not saying that you did I'm
just wondering about the broader
question of assuring the public that the
economy is fine and coronavirus can be
managed when of course given your
position you know that that's not true
so I'm asking Tucker that's not true
Tucker we just had an employment reports
that were strong in fact January are an
important employment 80,000 additional
workers were added to the payrolls once
February was reported so we've created
like 600,000 jobs this year we have very
strong members and heading into March
none of us knew where we would stand on
March 20th we are where we are today we
need to turn our focus to the American
people people are hurting they're
wondering about their jobs what's
happening their family 30 million kids
are out of school 5 to 7 million
waiters waitresses line chefs are out of
work oh I'm very aware no no we do show
something absolutely we do shows on it
every night and we share your concern a
hundred percent so your colleague
Richard Berg do you think that he should
be indicted for what he apparently did
of course it would be illegal to use
information he obtained in the Senate to
profit he clearly did that should he be
indicted for it should he resign
look Tucker I've been in the Senate 11
weeks I spent a lot of time in advance
getting my own situation set before I
came to the Senate I didn't advise my
colleagues on how they manage their
financial situations I don't know what
his situation is I can't speak for him
and I won't speak for him I think he's
been very forthcoming in terms of saying
the
he's willing to step in front of the
Senate Ethics Committee and I applaud
that well no but I'm not asking you to
give him financial advice obviously or
to tell him what he should do next I'm
just wondering what you think should
happen next do you think that given what
we know and he has conceded that he made
these trades himself at exactly the same
time that he was assuring the public
everything was fine he lied and you
believe that going before the Senate
Ethics Committee I've been in Washington
my whole life I'm not even sure what
that is
I know that nothing happens there you
think that's an adequate response look
Tucker I don't know what Senator Byrd
knew or knows I can't predict what his
state of mind will be in front of the
Senate Ethics Committee what it was when
he made decisions about those trades
what information he had I know that you
know many of our briefings were and
instantly out on Twitter as soon as I
walked out of the meeting these were
called closed meetings they weren't
classified they were closed but as soon
as I got out the information was already
on Twitter is in the public domain right
well but here you have and again you
don't need to speak for it Richard Burr
but I just want to be clear for our
audience and I wouldn't ask you to but
he was he wrote an op-ed on our website
saying it you know everything we're good
to go everything's fine you know we're
in good shape and then he gives this
speech comparing coronavirus to the
Spanish flu epidemic of 1918 that killed
up to 100 million people so you have to
think there's a massive disconnect
between what he's saying in public and
what he privately believes is that a
problem if if there are leaders on all
sides and I would say the same by the
way of Dianne Feinstein who behaved
disgracefully as well I mean it's not a
problem do you think well Tucker it
comes down to the timeline this is a
fast-moving situation and you know I
think we have to lay it out and say you
know what did we know and when and what
did you say and when and none of us
believed today what we believed on
February 1st February 1st we were locked
into impeachment we were heading into
the State of the Union we were having
the prayer breakfast there were a
million things going on in Washington no
one was locked down
other than president Trump had rightly
said what we need to seal off the border
from flights coming in from China
because there were 24 deaths in the
Wuhan province amen and I'm glad that he
did that
I got a briefing from or I had a long
conversation closed her conversation
with with the government official very
well very well informed government
official in February 3rd I checked my
date book on it and he said to me you
know millions of people ultimately could
die of this and we went immediately on
the air that night I didn't say that I
had spoken to someone about it but we
reported the substance of it which is as
scary as hell no one's paying attention
so I mean it was it was out there and I
guess it doesn't doesn't help anybody to
like sort of point fingers retro
actively but you you want to think that
your leaders are putting your interests
before theirs and and I wonder if that's
always happening well I think with
President Trump at the helm they he is
and our leaders are you can see dr.
pouchy you can see all the health care
leaders the economic leaders they're
putting us first senator Burr has
stepped forward and said he'd be willing
to step into the Senate ethics process
and I think that's all we can do is go
for that from there right okay
I was that's one last question have you
heard today I mean it's I'm just this an
editorial comment but I can't control
myself it's hard to believe that Richard
Burr and I and I agree with him on most
political issues so it's not like I've
got political bias here at all but do
you think he can keep his Senate seat
after this I mean what message would
that send to the country look Tucker I'm
a political outsider I'm here working to
try to solve for coronavirus I can't
predict where political outcomes may
evolve to but I'm just telling you right
now I'm focused on working for the
Georgia the state of Georgia for the
American people and making sure that we
solve the coronavirus and letting this
play out in the in the proper venue okay
well I appreciate it and I'm and I'm
really do want government to be solved
on focus on solving this sorry I
appreciate that senator thanks a lot for
joining us tonight Thank You Tucker